you know our schedule here on pop
culture explain is supposed to be
one celebrity or pop culture icon
explained on monday and then one
division on friday and we are basically
doing way more than that
but i can't help it it's one division
it's the coolest show out on tv right
now so here's the thing
i was looking over your all's comments
on the community tab and in the youtube
channel because i love reading girl's
comments and i was looking over all the
different theories and ideas you guys
had so i looked at the different ideas
you guys had and then i got with my fans
on the discord server and i started kind
of putting things together
i think for the most part we kind of
have it lined up so here's what's going
on in one division as crazy as this
might sound right here's what's going on
the biggest question that we kind of
have to ask here is how did wanda go
from a person that had telekinesis to a
person who could alter reality and we've
offered different ideas in the past of
her having like the dark hold or being
influenced by like mephisto
or dormammu or something like that the
biggest issue that you have here though
is you have to look at this from the
perspective of people who don't read
comics as a comic book reader i expect
stuff like that right i'd expect a story
in wine division where like ultron came
from the future
and like he influenced wanda with the
mind stone because she was blasted by
the energy when vision was destroyed
when the mindset was destroyed and like
avengers
infinity war that would make sense to me
as a comic book fan for a person doesn't
read comics that sounds ridiculous and
the marvel cinematic universe largely
builds itself on the simplest
explanation right occam's razor the
simplest explanation
tends to be the best one so we're gonna
go that route we're gonna strip away the
idea of mephisto we're going to strip
away
nightmare indoor mamu and all that kind
of stuff we're going to remove all of
that
instead we're going to look at two
things we're going to look at a handful
of comics we're going to look at doctor
strange the multiverse of madness and
we're going to look at agatha harkness
so here's the idea here
in terms of wanda having these abilities
my stance at least my new stance anyway
is she's always had these powers
right wanda has always had these
abilities she's always had the power to
alter reality that's not anything new
it's just she never realized it she's
only ever really been able to use the
ability for like telekinesis so my
argument is
wanda's always had those powers question
answered now the question becomes if
she's always had those powers
what happened over the course of the
last three weeks that she was suddenly
able to use those
because remember one division picks up
three weeks after the end of avengers
end game and so we can largely assume
that the events of one division began
somewhere between one to two weeks after
the events of avengers end game so my
thought is this that wanda ended up
going to doctor strange or doctor
strange sought her out but it's most
likely she went to stephen strange and
was basically looking for ways to learn
her abilities right learning what she's
capable of or maybe stephen strange went
to her and said hey like you have these
crazy abilities you can do a lot more
than you think you can but i personally
don't have time to train you so i can
refer you to a colleague
this colleague was agatha harkness that
doctor strange
basically referred wanda to agatha in
west view now when wanda
got to agatha harkness that i get the
hardness basically did what she did in
marvel comics with the celestial madonna
story those of you guys don't know what
that is the celestial madonna was a
story arc that was covered in avengers
issues 129 through 135. if anybody wants
to go check those out and while there
was a lot of other stuff going on kane
of copper
ultron things like that a background
story that became important at the end
of celestial madonna was
wanda learning how to use her powers
from agatha it was agatha teaching her
her abilities because up to that point
all wanda had was hex powers and they
would manifest themselves in random ways
so there was one instance for example
where the avengers were fighting ultron
and wanda used her hex powers and there
was like some small little short circuit
in ultron that allowed them to win and
that was it it's just those small little
bending luck to her favorite kind of
things
but wanda knew and dr strange knew that
wanda was capable of a lot
more than she initially seemed to be and
so agatha took wanda under her wing and
taught her all kinds of stuff
right she had things like she had a
chair get up and walk around at the end
of the story you ended up having a
scenario where wanda
actually saved vision and uh and agnes
from dormammu right from the power that
that guy possessed so that was really
the first indication that marvel gave us
that wanda is immensely powerful and so
my thought here
is that wanda basically went to agatha
and agatha said okay
i'll teach you how to use your powers
i'll teach you how to use your abilities
the problem with this
is that agnes got more than she
bargained for the devil's in the details
well that's not the only place he is
right sometimes the devil isn't the
mistakes that we make in our own
arrogance our belief that we are capable
of more than we really are that maybe
agatha looked at wanda and said well how
bad could it really be and wanda
basically turned into frankenstein's
monster
she kind of turned into a position to
where her creator couldn't keep her
under control juana's powers began to
manifest now the question becomes how do
we go from
wanda learning how to use her powers
under the training of agatha harkness to
the events of wand division so let's say
that over the course of this time period
while the relationship between agatha
and wanda is not enough it doesn't
really grow to the point that it becomes
a mother-daughter relationship because
that'd be kind of wild if it happened
over three weeks let's say that they
grow a kind of admirable respect for
each other right and if they follow the
comic book line
then wanda stayed with agatha for a
period of time she basically stayed with
her and resided in her residence and
learned how to use her powers then
in turn they'd have conversations and
they would talk and they would get to
know each other better and maybe it's
one of these things where it was some
kind of offhanded remark from agatha
harkness directly to wanda where wanda's
like yeah you know i'd give anything to
be able to live this perfect life that i
always imagined myself
living when i was watching sitcoms and i
was living in sokovia as a little kid
and i guess it makes some responses
saying well i mean you know with your
kind of power you could do almost
anything you want to
or she makes some kind of response and
she says well i mean you know like if
only we could all just create our own
reality and live in it this perfect life
forever maybe just some kind of
offhanded remark now the reason why that
matters is because that's what happened
to franklin richards in marvel comics
when franklin ridge was a little kid he
didn't have the ability to use his
powers
in any real direct sense he could but
they manifested randomly you never
really knew what he was going to do and
there was a point in the old fantastic
four comics when he was playing with a
rubik's cube and he was getting
frustrated with the fact that he
couldn't solve this rubik's cube and at
the same time that was going on
there was a television show playing and
the television show had this offhanded
remark that said when are you gonna grow
up and franklin richards
subconsciously aged himself up into an
adult and the story unfolds from there
that's entirely possible that that's
what happened here that wanda
may not necessarily have had any kind of
a psychotic breakdown or anything along
those lines it's just she realized she
could
right that it's just one of these things
where agatha made this remark and saying
well i mean you could create your own
reality if you wanted to and she didn't
say it on the thing that like yes
wanda alter west view and make us all
puppets under your whim
that is just one of these things where
it was just kind of a thoughtless
off-handed remark and then wanda kind of
sits there for a minute and she's like
actually i can't i can do that right
given the kind of power that she has and
then she does it right she just takes
over westview and everybody there is
just acting out a role that she plays
for them and there's a few things that
we see we already had a few instances
for example when monica rambo was pulled
into uh into west view and she was
pulled into wanda's world then when
wanda asked her what her name was monica
was kind of remembering it for a second
now we could interpret that in a couple
different ways that monica was totally
aware of what she was doing
and that she's kind of like okay i'm
playing a role here so that i don't get
destroyed or whatever
or it could be one of those things that
like the the bee suit and like the jump
rope and like you know the helicopter
that flew into the one division world
that monica was taken over as well
and that she didn't really know what her
name was because she hadn't been given
one up to that point but then as soon as
juana asked her what her name is and it
was geraldine and that would explain why
she looks confused as she's giving her
name because she can't remember it
that's why she looks a little confused
when she's talking about ultron and it's
like she's remembering it as she's
saying it she's snapping back to reality
and the way things are supposed to be
and breaking free of wanda's influence
or at least juana's influence was
weakening because she was sort of lost
in thought and focused on her brother
pietro and his death at the hands of
ultron
and not focusing on controlling the
reality as it existed at that point in
time
i think it all works out i think it all
really really comes together and so we
know that wanda vision
directly segues into the events of
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness here's my question what if in
the multiverse of madness is not
designed to be a title to indicate that
the multiverse has just descended into
chaos that dormammus free or mephistos
free or nightmares free or something
like that it's a title that's just
designed to indicate that the multiverse
is something that's just never really
been explored by wanda or doctor strange
and there's all kinds of crazy kooky
wild things the ancient one said that in
doctor strange one that the multiverse
was this great big huge place with all
kinds of dangers and if she told steven
strange
everything that he didn't already know
that he would just run in terror
from everything that that he would
basically end up learning so we know the
multiverse can be a pretty chaotic and a
pretty wild place
so it's not really designed to be a
movie it's not really designed to be a
title that says like dormammu got free
and now scarlet witch is influenced by
dormammu so doctor strange saves her and
then the two of them go off and fight
doramu that's not really what it is
instead what would most likely happen
here is that when one division is all
said and done
then it becomes apparent agatha cannot
adequately train wanda because her power
is just too extreme and so stephen
strange has to be the one to do it
instead she basically becomes the
student
of doctor strange and the two of them go
into the multiverse and basically
explore it because steven strange might
figure hey two heads are better than one
when it comes to facing off against this
kind of stuff you know you cover my back
i'll cover yours and we'll be like
batman and robin you know that kind of a
thing and they're basically out there
fighting in the multiverse doing their
thing some kind of an event might take
place like what we saw in celestial
madonna where wanda will have to save
stephen strange from some kind of threat
that's out there but by and large that
looks like that's the case
right that there is basically just a
movie designed to have wanda operate as
the student of steven strange learning
more about how to use her powers and how
to control her powers as the film goes
on
so that's my theory on wanda vision it's
simple it's pretty straight to the point
it's not overly complex it doesn't
require us to bring in all these crazy
comic book concepts and i think it works
because the mcu
is a line of films and tv shows that
pride themselves on simplicity so let me
know what you guys think in the comments
section thank you guys for watching make
sure you guys check
our videos on the wanda vision easter
eggs and theories and all that kind of
stuff you'll find an
end screen here in the video and i will
catch you all later
peace